[Musique]
les
JS
cour V reprendre
justement mais dans des conditions dans
un théâtre avec une très bonne
sonorisation que le public soit bien
installé
avecussies musical que depuis quelqu
temps maintenant comme un
spectacle vent une rencontre ma
Rodrig
r une petite équipe est comme çavec G à
s'échanger aussi une espè d'alchimie a
li
[Musique]
entreoup compréhension et changement
inévitable comprend que l'amour un
équation parce que même l'amour éternel
transform
enissable le créole c'est la vie c'est
c'est ma langue maternelle c'est la
langue maternelle de tellement de gens
formidable et l'année dernière j'ai eu
la chance de participer de découvrir le
cocktail F care donc un spectacle qui
rend
hommageant qui depuis longtemps ETI la
poésie en général et la lang cré
oup grand
ance
[Musique]
pourex qui je suis vraiment qui est
avant et moi je
suisis et
maen
[Musique]
p